qu'est ce qui vous fascine le plus dans
le monde du x une certaine indépendance
et s'associe bien de la femme et des
hommes est certaine égalité au niveau du
travail même si les salaires des hommes
sont un peu plus bas au final l'homme
est très important moi je revendique le
fait de dire que le hardeur et 13 autres
c'est très important avec qui on
travaille
si nous met mal à l'aise ou si on
s'entend pas avec forcément en fera une
mauvaise scène mais c'est vrai que la
femme
et un peu plus central donc du coup
forcément un gagner un peu plus d'argent
quels souvenirs gardez vous de votre
premier film x en tant qu'actrice puis
en tant que spectatrice mon premier tout
premier film et je m'en souviens c'est
je crois ce site je suis un pas du titre
jamais regarder ça avec des potes ont
gardé ça en fait semblant que ça nous
excite est pas alors qu'en fait ça nous
titiller un peu mais il y avait une
pudeur qui faisait que 11 et or c'est
marrant alors en fait on était là un peu
chaud le souvenir en tant qu'actrice
pour mon premier film professionnel je
sais pas peut-être tout le tout les
moyens techniques même s'ils sont pas
aussi grand que dans le cinéma
traditionnel
le maquillage le petit pompeux nageons
après s'en être une petite princesse
même si on va se faire défoncer après et
c'est ça avez vous un film x culte je me
souviens d'un film qui ait marqué
c'était la princesse et la avec
comment elle s'appelle à la dorsale girl
lors sinclair lors sinclair joue la
sainte nitouche à la fin elle se fait
baiser devant tout le monde dans le club
un peu méchant c'est pas vraiment un
club échangiste on va dire ça comme ça
et donc ce côté-là sainte nitouche qui
devient une vraie et samassa
matelas qui m'a plu dans le film qu'est
ce qui vous a le plus marqué depuis vos
débuts dans l'univers du x
les rencontre pas forcément dans le cul
parce que j'avais déjà une vie sexuelle
à 6 mouvementée avant luxe j'ai pas
appris grand chose au beau fixe mais
c'est plus les rencontres les
les différentes personnes que j'ai
rencontrées les amis j'ai rencontré mon
mec j'ai enfin voilà quoi c'est me suis
fait une petite famille dans l'équipe
avez vous envie de passer derrière la
caméra
j'ai des idées après j'ai pas les moyens
j'aimerais bien faire un truc avec une
domination de la femme sur une autre
femme un peu à la histoire d'eau en plus
soft mais
ou un truc comme ça quand j'ai pas tout
raconter sinon à me piquer mes idées
quel a été pour vous la scène la plus
difficile à tourner une scène avec que
bruno mon partenaire on a fait une scène
un peu et scène pour dominique girl en
hongrie où justement il me dominer et
moi j'aime bien des fois être un petit
peu soumises j'aime bien aussi avec
dominante mais je suis pas une vraie
soumises
donc c'est assez difficile même si les
lycées peuvent faire mal les positions
gondjout ça c'est avec un autre ça
serait peut-être fasse passer plus
facilement et pour moi ça a été très dur
psychologiquement la faire cette scène
quel est le partenaire idéal de tournage
j'aurais dit mon partenaire nous mais ça
fait un peu trop puis comme le dit ça
dépend vraiment des scènes mais c'est
vrai qu'on s'entend vraiment très bien
en ce qui concerne en fait on a la même
vision du porno en général comment faire
nous on ce qu'on veut c'est pas
forcément prendre notre pied même si
tant mieux si on prend notre pied mais
c'est faire une belle scène et que le
réalisateur soit content et après qu'on
nous dise par les mecs qui regarde où
les coupes ou les femmes que qu'ils ont
apprécié avec quelle star du x aimeriez
vous collaborez tarra white
j'ai déjà fait une scène avec elle mais
je n'ai pas touché donc j'en suis resté
frustré et j'aimerais en faire une
une vraie on se défoule et de tara si tu
m'écoutes quelle est la réaction la plus
courante quand on vous reconnaît dans la
rue
la plupart du temps les mecs toi hésite
je vois qu'ils me regardent ils hésitent
et puis fait excuse moi je ne serai pas
je t'aurais pas vu quelque part à la
télé dans un film
ils sont très timides en général et je
trouve ça super mignon qu'avez-vous
appris sur vous en travaillant dans le x
j'étais un petit peu garçon manqué en
arrivant et du coup j'ai appris à
devenir plus féminine à maquiller un
mobilier
dans votre filmographie quel est le
titre de film que vous préférez
justement voilà je cherche le
réalisateur qui va me donner le film que
je vais revenir le titre toute ma vie
j'ai fait roi moi j'ai joué dans ce film
là et je veux vraiment le type sites de
films bien porno un peu pour ifs est en
revanche y avez vous un fantasme
avouables j'aimerais bien faire une
grosse grosse orgie de femmes mais bien
sauvage pas un truc love par un truc
sont violés enfin ce viol tout l'une
entre autres un viol de meuf quel autre
métier auriez vous pu oui mais faire là
bas un rêve quand j'étais plus jeune
avant de faire du porno je voulais être
mécanicienne j'aurais aimé travailler
pour l'écurie de citroën en compagnie de
sébastien loeb est de monter démonter
remonter préparer sa voiture pour le wrc
c'était un de mes rêves que
j'ai essayé de faire j'ai fait la
formation pour faire ça mais j'ai vite
arrêté parce que c'était trop macho pour
moi quel est votre principal plaisir
professionnels au début c'était le sexe
review je faisais vraiment ça pointu
mais bon après on n'est pas que des
machines donc forcément il ya autre
chose c'est de jouer des rôles de l'aide
d'une être une personne sans être
schizophrène et
oui d'avoir la possibilité de faire
paître plusieurs personnes en même temps
quelle est votre principale qualité sur
un plateau je pense être quelqu'un de
très professionnel j'essaie d'arriver à
l'heure j'essaye de savoir mon texte je
suis aimable avec les gens quand je suis
sur une scène je veux pas faire chier le
mec ou la meuf en disant non mais ça ça
me plaît pas ça ça me fait penser au
fait avec bruno ce que je peux me
permettre
quel est votre principal défaut mais des
fois je vais essayer de plus se mettre
hors tournage parce que dans ton âge le
problème c'est qu'il faut éviter de
faire comme dans tous les boulots en
faut éviter de faire ressortir un
maximum ses défauts pour pas handicaper
les personnes avec qui tu travailles et
enfin que peut-on vous souhaiter
aujourd'hui que ça continue
[Applaudissements]